my favorites
I wrote this song about a guy who I was
dating and he was just a freshman in
high school when she wrote that wise
beyond your years and boys for world
domination so grateful this time last
year you know I was just coming here and
basically observing and this year I'm
nominated is performing and that there's
no better feeling than fan she'd won ten
Grammys and amassed a reported 250
million dollar fortune it's been an
absolute complete whirlwind I mean my
18th birthday is next week and you know
album just went double platinum and now
this and I literally was standing
backstage going how did this happen how
does how did my life get this awesome so
fast
how do you handle and deal with all the
rumors that are flying around about you
and these guys you live your life in
spite of what people write about it and
my personal life is is that and I like
it when people write about my music
truth is she's written just as much
about her personal life her music as the
press has Taylor's had some seriously
famous exes Joe Jonas Taylor Lautner
John Mayer Harry Styles
Calvin Harris and who can forget Kittel
Swift but one thing's for sure the girl
knows how to channel heartache into a
hit single
this one was reportedly for Jake
Gyllenhaal who she dated for just three
months before he broke up with her in a
text
jinnie the guys never asked you in the
beginning hey Ari if this doesn't work
out are you gonna write about me no they
say that in the ending thank you
no they never they never go into this
and be like I really want to ask you out
could you not write songs about us they
say that when we're breaking up like you
better not read song about this and I'm
like oh I won't and then I do and when
it comes to Taylor's style evolution
we've watched her grow from that
wide-eyed 16 year old who wore pink to
her first red carpet event hearing like
a pink princess dress you know you feel
like a princess and it's amazing to an
all-out fashion icon and self professed
control freak has given us some major
squad goals and a stone Kendall Jenner
Gigi Hadid Selena they're all in the
inner Swift sanctum you talked to Taylor
if you guys talk about em for date are
you yeah what are the characteristics of
a great friend oh I think sincerity I
mean my friends are so different but the
thing that they all have in common is
sincerity we would never turn on each
other we're not gonna you know gossip
about each other it's like kind of like
this alliance but over the years
Taylor's always told us it's all about
keeping that ego you should you're
Taylor Swift it's okay you can do
whatever you want to the graphs aren't
start saying things to me like that
that's what we get weird
really you cannot why do you think you
feel like it could all go away tomorrow
because it could I don't know you're in
a pretty good track here yeah but you
know if that's just how it works like
you just have to like anything can
change in an instant
and you just have to appreciate the fact
that you get to do what you love one
more day and that keeps you in
perspective